yes hello hi is is this IT hi IT this is
Elliott yeah yeah I was just wondering
them who do I call to find out how to
work the phones well I don't know no no
I'm not I'm not crying yeah no I know
it's part of my job to to call clients
and yeah I know that I'm on the phone
right now well when you're in an
elevator do you know exactly how that
works
hello okay do you honestly not know how
to phones work what oh oh okay don't
worry uh don't cry or anything I got it
here here I got it all better
Thanks no problem have a good one no
problem I have a good one I will Anna I
will have a good one hey there Harper
you having some trouble with the old
copy guy yeah it's not working as always
you want to step aside and let me give
it a shot
yeah go for please all right boom it's
working did it Elliot fix the copier
guys your fly thanks Ari
let's let's doing it easy
we got a call from corporate about
yesterday's reports because they found
the discrepancy inside the numbers oh
yeah I straighten them out what they
were just using the wrong algorithm so
there was on their site you called
corporate yeah and talked to a person
yep
you didn't cry nope no tears you are
doing yourself do Wow no problem have a
good one
the meeting is not over Balian hey our
prayers
oh your fly oh I know your fly no your
pants fly is open
oh how long has it been I don't know I
try to tell you this morning
Elliot fix the copier guy no problem no
no oh God okay what the hello what what
is it I don't yes
no this is Elliot oh yeah that's the
discrepancy is coming from inside the
numbers
you